Big- time win for the First Amendment,
for free speech, and yes indeed for gun
tubers, many of whom could have been at
risk if this decision came out the other
way. But I'm glad it did not do so.
Let's talk about it when we come right
back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Barn, and
I'm proud to say the top voice of the
Second Amendment in America. Thank you.
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. This is a big deal. big deal, big
win for the first amendment. But it goes
even beyond that because there was a
risk here that ordinary licensed
professionals in any profession could
have had their first amendment right to
free speech to talk about the issues
they see inappropriate could have been
shut down as a condition of maintaining
your professional license. We'll get to
that in one second. Bottom line is a
woman named Kaylee Charles was a
Colorado licensed mental health
counselor who provided talk therapy. She
talked to people. She didn't prescribe
medicine. She didn't touch people. She
simply talked to people as part of basic
talk therapy helping people with various
problems. One group of clients were
minors that uh felt either attracted to
the same sex and or thought maybe they
were a girl and a boy's body or a boy
and a girl's body and they had gender
related issues, maybe gender dysphoria.
And in 2019, Colorado passed a law that
says that if you're a talk therapist
licensed by the state, that's the key,
licensed by the state, then you're only
allowed to encourage boys who want to be
girls to become girls and girls that
want to become boys to become boys. In
other words, you could advise them and
exercise your free speech and talk
therapy authority and rights to
encourage the transition from one gender
to another. But what you could not do is
to discourage that transition. So you're
only allowed to say if you think you're
a boy, but you're in a girl's body,
you're not you're allowed to say under
Colorado law that yes, let's help you
transition from being a girl to a boy.
But what you could not do is the reverse
to say, well, you're a girl, but maybe
you're going through some stress. Maybe
you really are a girl. Let's talk this
through before we transition you to a
different gender. And this is the sort
of thing that was going on that Colorado
said, here's the key and this is how it
ties into gun tubers like a William Kirk
or Tom Grieve or any attorney that talks
about things and it doesn't have to be
an attorney. It could be a medical
professional, could be anyone with a
license, even theoretically plumbing
licenses or electrical licenses. Anyone
with a license was at risk from this
case. And why do I say that? If you look
at the descent in this 8 to1 decision by
you guessed it, Justice Can Brown
Jackson, what she basically said was
this that once you get a professional
license from the state for you to
practice your profession, in this case
it was a therapist, right? Um Charles
Kaylee Charles was a Colorado licensed
mental health counselor, but it could
apply to any profession, any licensed
profession. So, Kataj Brown Jackson says
that once you become a licensed
professional, the state can set
conditions on what you can on cannot say
as part of the argument that they are
allowed to regulate the industry. Which
means like hypothetically, let's say the
bar association, the state bar says, you
know what, we don't want Mark or anybody
supporting the right to keep and bear
arms. We think that hurts the
profession. And as part of our authority
to regulate the profession, we're going
to issue a guidance that says that if
you come out in support of armed
citizens, the right to bear arms, armed
self-defense, or any of these things, we
think that that hurts the profession of
the practice of law. And we're going to
say either shut up on the topic or argue
in favor of gun control law, or you're
going to lose your license or be at risk
of professional discipline. Obviously,
that would be a problem. But Katanji
Brown Jackson doesn't appear to think
that's a problem. She thinks that the
authority of states to regulate a
profession is so broad that in theory
you could get away with something like
that if you're the state of Colorado,
apparently. But I'm happy to report in
this 8 to1 decision written by Justice
Neil Gorsuch, a Trump appointee, he
specifically said that the Colorado law
that allows for advice only one way but
not the other way, violates the First
Amendment. As you know, the First
Amendment speaks to the right to free
speech. And under long-standing Supreme
Court president, there is no more
obvious type of speech than talking,
right? Talking is the ultimate form of
speech. Talking and writing. And because
Kaylee Charles, you know, speaks and she
doesn't like prescribe medicine. She
doesn't engage in third surgery or
anything like that. The only thing
that's being regulated here as applied
to Miss Charles, the plaintiff of this
case, was what she was allowed to say.
And thus the Colorado law here
discriminated against the viewpoint that
she wanted to be able to talk about with
her clients and her patients. And the
Supreme Court said that the Colorado law
could not use as an excuse the
regulation of a licensed professional to
basically allow for the restriction on
the types of speech that in this case,
Miss Charles could have with her clients
and her patients. And this is a big win.
Now remember, um, if you're a licensed
professional,
there's often the case that the
professionals view your behavior not
just as, uh, what you say and what you
do, but also how you make the profession
look. So, for example, if you're a
YouTuber with a law license or a medical
license or a psychological license, uh,
right? you're a psychiatrist, whatever,
you have a license to practice and you
go on YouTube or you go on Rumble and
you go on social media and you
articulate views the profession doesn't
like under the view of Kanji Brown
Jackson that state regulated the bar,
the medical licensing board, whatever it
is, they would have the authority to say
that what you're saying is sort of
denigrating and harmful to the
profession. And since you're, let's say,
I don't know, an officer of the court or
whatever, uh, we don't want you to be
able to say that. And if you say that,
we're going to put your license at risk.
So, you better shut up and do what we
say. And that was essentially what was
the issue in this case. But again, in
the 81 decision by Neil Gorsuch, big win
for the First Amendment, they said, and
this is key, the Supreme Court says just
because you get a license from the
government does not mean you wave your
right to free speech, which by extension
means you also do not wave other rights
like your right to keep and bear arms.
that can be very important down the
road. So with that said, let's take a
look specifically at one of the great
paragraphs that Justice Gorsuch's writes
explaining the importance of the First
Amendment right to free speech. And as
you know, when it comes to the Second
Amendment, if you and I cannot defend
the Second Amendment right to keep and
bear arms in social media or in public,
then we're going to lose our Second
Amendment rights because we need to be
able to advocate for and educate people
about the right to keep and bear arms.
And if we're shut down and prevented
from doing so because it risk our
license or whatever conditions uh the
government has. I mean it can even go
beyond that. So just think
hypothetically speaking, let's say you
want to add a barn or an addition to
your home or you want to remodel a
kitchen or whatever it is in theory,
right? U you could they could say, well,
you know, if you want to remodel your
home or or build a barn or do something
to develop your property, that's fine.
But as a condition of getting that
license, as a condition of getting that
permit, we need you to say X, Y, and Z
and not say not X, Y, and Z. And if you
say something we don't approve of or you
tow the line that you don't we don't
approve of, that could be a problem.
Obviously, that would be another
illustration of a violation of the First
Amendment's right to free speech, which
was reaffirmed today in this very
important case of Charles versus
Salazar. So, as I've explained to you
before, you have to understand how all
these constitutional issues all work
together to protect our individual
rights because it's not just about
having a gun and the right to bear arms.
You have to protect all these other
aspects of American law that protect our
liberties, including the first amendment
right to free speech as well as other
issues like the fourth, the fifth, the
sixth, the eth, and the ninth amendments
and all these other things all work
together to protect our individual
liberties. So, with that said, here's
what Justice Gors had to say about the
first amendment. I think you'll find it
interesting. The First Amendment stands
as a shield against any effort to
enforce orthodoxy in thought or speech
in this country. It reflects instead a
judgment that every American possesses,
an inalienable right to think and speak
freely, and a faith in the free
marketplace of ideas as the best means
for discovering truth. However
well-intentioned any law, any law that
suppresses speech based on viewpoint
that represents based on viewpoint
represents an egregious assault on both
of those commitments. That's exactly
right. It's very important that we be
able to speak. The best way to get the
truth is the ability to rebut things.
Obviously, the sorts of things that are
said about guns and guns being
dangerous. If we did not have the buddy
ability to rebut those with statistics,
with data, with arguments, then you know
you're going to have uh a single
monolithic view of the world, which in
the case of the second amendment would
be against us because up until recently,
the anti-Americans controlled the
mainstream media and they controlled the
messaging. They had all the choke points
to the public. But I'm happy to report
with things like Rumble, YouTube, social
media, Elon Musk X, uh the monopoly on
the message has been lost. In part, I'd
like to think because of the rise of
channels like the four boxes diner,
standing, of course, for the four boxes
of American liberty. For those of you
who may be wondering, the four boxes of
American liberty are the soap box for
free speech, the cartridge box for the
right to bear arms, the voting box,
which is of course the ballot box, and
the voting box. You vote together, you
got to vote, and of course, last but not
least, the jury box, which speaks to,
you guessed it, the rule of law. You
need those four boxes of American
liberty to be a full American citizen.
And thus the channel is named after the
four boxes of American liberty and Dina
refers to casual conversation as opposed
to me put it on an academic groebe and
lecturing you. And the last point that
Justice Gorsuch made in this powerful
8:1 decision in favor of our first
amendment rights which we really need to
protect among other things our second
amendment rights. Here's what he had to
say. Check it out. We have recognized as
well the even greater dangers associated
with regulations that discriminate based
on a speaker's point of view. When the
government seeks not just to restrict
speech based on its subject matter, but
it also seeks to dictate what particular
opinion or perspective individuals may
express on that subject, the violation
of the first amendment is all the more
blatant. While the First Amendment
protects many and varied forms of
expression, the spoken word is perhaps
the quintessential form of protected
speech. And that is exactly the kind of
expression in which Miss Child seeks to
engage. as a talk therapist. All Miss
Childles does is speak with clients. She
does not prescribe medicine. She does
not use medical devices and she does not
employ any physical methods. Period. All
right, folks. So, I think this is again
more good news for the First Amendment,
one of our fundamental rights. And I do
think this speaks to this court's
commitment of willing to step up and
fight for all the fundamental rights.
Obviously, we have more work to do when
it comes to the Second Amendment rights,
but I think again the trend is our
friend and uh candles lit and fingers
crossed that we're going to continue to
have more good results from the Supreme
Court and frankly all aspects of
government. I hope moving forward. But
with that said, I hope you enjoyed
today's episode here at the Four Boxes
Diner. Make sure you follow me over
there at X4boxes
Diner. Don't forget to subscribe both
the YouTube and the Rumble and I will
talk to all of you again real soon here
at the Four Boxes Diner. Orders up.
Table 2 A.